There's a fundamental problem with AI
models. Whenever you give them tasks,
they never take ownership of that task,
and this is why we always have to review
the agent's output because we cannot
trust it. But this laziness problem just
got solved. So, GitHub's number one
trending author has a solution for this,
and this is the person who also made the
design taste skill, which is one of the
most popular design skills out right
now. He has built a new skill called
Unlazy that solves this exact problem in
AI agents. The workflow behind Unlazy is
really creative. But after running it
ourselves, we came across a huge problem
with how slow it was, and we found a way
to fix that as well. Now, if you're new
here, then welcome. We're a software
company, and this is AI labs. In this
video, we're going over what Unlazy is,
how it actually works, the problem it
has, and the change we made to fix it.
Now, laziness is a problem that
basically shows up no matter which model
you're using, even the most powerful
ones like Opus and GPT 5.6. It just
becomes easier to notice in the smaller
models because they have far fewer
capabilities, and their limitations
become obvious much faster. And Unlazy
is built to fix exactly that. This skill
forces the agent to stop being lazy with
its inbuilt mechanism and deliver what
you actually need. And the main idea
behind it is that it doesn't tell you
the agent is done, it proves it. It
checks the work against a ledger, which
is basically a checklist where every
item has to have proof that it's
actually done. So, instead of just
telling you the work is complete, it
shows you the proof for every part of
it. And it works with all the popular
agents like Claude Code, Codex, and
more. But to understand why this skill
matters, you need to know what happens
without it and how adding this one
solves that problem. But before we go
deeper into it, it would be great if you
subscribe to the channel and hit the
hype button. This small gesture of
support goes a long way for us.
>> [snorts]
>> Now, before actually exploring the
skill, we need to understand why the
agents get lazy in the first place. Now,
on a fresh context window, you might not
notice that at all. There's barely
anything in there yet, which is why the
model can focus way better on the task
you gave it. But, it will be more
visible as the context fills up. Now,
these models don't have any inbuilt
memory, so they actually don't know what
happened in the previous message you
sent. So, how does it know what happened
before? These agents send all of the
previous messages along with your new
prompt, so the model knows what has
already happened. But, as you send more
and more messages, that pile keeps
growing, and there's a lot more for the
model to pay attention to at one time.
And this is exactly why the agents
aren't able to focus as clearly on each
part of the task and just slack off
while they're working through it. And
this laziness happens in two different
ways. The first is that the agent tells
you it's done when it isn't. There's
been many times when you ask Claude code
to work through many files, it just
opens a few instead of actually looking
at all of them and reports that it went
through everything. And that's the part
that actually costs you. A model that
stops early with clearly unfinished work
is acceptable, but when it stops early
and tells you it finished everything,
that's where it becomes a problem. You
don't actually know if it's completed
until you verify it yourself. So, if you
don't, and you build more on top of that
unfinished work, you're going to run
into problems in the long run. And the
second is that it shrinks the job
without telling you. So, for example,
you ask for something that has five
parts to it, and one of those parts is
difficult. It builds the four easy ones
and skips the hard one. And the summary
you get at the end never mentions
anything's missing. Now, you might be
thinking this isn't a new problem, and
you'd be right, because these problems
have always been there with these
agents, and people have been building
fixes for them for a long time. You
probably already know about the Ralph
loop. That one keeps sending the agent
back the same prompt again and again
until an indicator in its output says
the task is done. And there's also
Claude's gold command, which uses
another model as a judge. And we've
built loops like this ourselves, too,
where a task list held the checks that
every task had to pass. But, all of
these have a limit to them. With Ralph,
that finish line is just a bit of text
the agent writes while it's working.
But, a a of tasks can't be judged by a
finish line. There's no single word that
tells you a feature is actually built
properly. And the goal command uses a
smaller model that reads through the
conversation to decide whether the work
is finished. So, it's judging by what
the conversation says instead of the
work itself, and it can drift from what
you actually needed. And with our own
loops, those checks were real, but it
was the agent itself that graded them.
So, it was still the agent deciding
whether it was done. And they can all
work really well when your context
window is fresh. But once you're deep in
the real work, they start to falter. And
that's exactly the point where you need
them to hold. But before we show the
whole workflow that fixes these
problems, let's have a word by our
sponsor, Data for SEO. If you vibe coded
an SEO tool or marketing dashboard, you
know it's only as good as the data
behind it. And real SEO data usually
means an expensive monthly subscription
before you've even shipped. Data for SEO
fixes that. It's one of the top SEO data
providers in the world with over 10 APIs
covering everything from keywords and
backlinks to competitor and AI search
visibility. In their dashboard, there's
an API playground. We typed in a keyword
and fired off one request and seconds
later had the search volume and top
ranking pages in front of us. Then it
handed us the code we plugged into the
app and our dashboard was pulling live
ranking in under a minute. Setup took
under 5 minutes. The pricing is where it
really wins. There's no subscription and
you pay as you go per request, so cost
scale as you grow. Plus real human
support around the clock, not a bot.
Normally, you'd start with a $1 trial.
Using our link bumps up to $5 in free
credits. Go build with it. The link's in
the pinned comment. Now, before we show
you how to set this up, let's look at
what's actually going on underneath and
how that solves the problem. So, when
you give this skill a large task, it
doesn't start working on it. It breaks
that task into smaller tasks first. And
then it takes each one of those and
breaks it into smaller tasks again. So,
the whole thing branches out, one task
turning into a few, and each of those
turning into a few more. And that's why
it's called a tree. And once it stops
splitting, every small task at the end
gets handed off to its own sub-agent.
And you're the one who controls how many
times that happens. So, when you write
your prompt, you say you want to use the
skill, and you give it a number along
with it. That number is the depth of the
tree. So, if you say five, the task gets
broken down five times over and no
further. And if you don't give it a
number at all, it picks the smallest one
that fits what you asked for. Now, the
reason it does any of this goes straight
back attention problem we just
mentioned. When the work is broken up
like this, each task has one clear goal,
and the agent working on it isn't
carrying the rest of the job around with
it. But, those tasks can't be too small,
either. The rule the skill gives is that
each one should be worth at least 10
minutes of real work, because it has to
be a proper piece of the job that an
agent can pick up and finish on its own.
So, if you set that number too high, and
the tasks come out smaller than the 10
minutes of work, the skill lowers the
split task to the default number, which
is three. And that number also decides
how the work runs. Three or under is
what the skill calls solo mode, and
that's the default. Everything stays in
one session, and the same agent works
through all of it. But, four and up
switches it into orchestrated mode, and
that's where it writes a lot more of it
down. It writes a plan file that holds
the whole breakdown, and then a separate
checklist for every single task in it.
And the reason it writes that down in a
file comes from how the previous version
of this skill failed. That one tried to
fix laziness by telling the agent to be
thorough. But, an instruction is the
first thing to get lost in a long
session, which is the exact problem it
was trying to fix. So, this version
stopped asking and started putting it in
a file before any work begins. That file
is the gates file, and it's the ledger
we mentioned at the start. And every
item in that file is called a gate. So,
each gate is a checkbox with an outcome
written next to it, which is one thing
that has to be true before the task
counts as done. And underneath that
outcome, there are three lines. The
first is the command that proves that
outcome has been achieved. The second is
the exact words that command has to give
back, and the third is the evidence,
which starts out just saying pending.
Then the skill comes with a checker, and
when you run it, it goes down that file
and runs every one of those commands
itself. If the answer that comes back
has the words the gate was expecting, it
ticks the box, and it replaces that
pending line with the bit of the answer
that decided it. And that evidence line
is what closes the hole in every fix we
listed earlier. A tick box with pending
still under it, it means the agent
ticked that box itself, which is just
the agent telling you it's done all over
again. So, it counts as unmet, and the
skill treats that as worse than an empty
box, because an empty box is at least
honest about where the work actually got
to. And that same rule is what keeps the
bigger runs honest. In orchestrated
mode, it hands one task to a fresh
agent, which only gets the plan and its
own gates file, nothing about the rest
of the job. But when that agent comes
back saying it's finished, the main one
doesn't take its word for it and runs
that task's checks against itself, and
only then does it write a line into the
plan file and hand out the next task.
And there's an honest way out, because
sometimes a task turns out to be
impossible. So, instead of the agent
dropping it and saying nothing, it
writes a line giving up on that gate by
name with the reason, and that goes into
the report you get at the end. So,
Unlazy is a whole system rather than a
single check at the end, and at no point
in it does the agent get to decide
whether the work is done. Now, to
actually [snorts] use the skill, you
need to install it first. So, you go to
their official GitHub page and look for
the install section, and that's where
you copy the command from. You can get
the link from the description below.
After that, you open the terminal inside
the project you're working on and run
it. And once you run it, the installer
starts, and the first thing it asks is
which agent you're using. If you're on
Code X, you don't need to change
anything there, because it installs into
the  agents folder that Code X
already reads from. But if you're on
Cloud Code, you select it from the menu
that opens. And you can pick as many of
the others as you want at the same time.
Then it asks you to choose the scope,
which is basically whether this skill
should only work inside the project
you're in right now, or whether you want
it available in everything you build. We
went with the project scope because we
wanted to test it against one specific
project first. After that, you go with
the recommended options, and that's the
install done. So, when you open that
project in VS Code, you'll see two new
folders, one called  agents and one
called  Claude, and they're not two
separate copies of it. The skill itself
actually lives in the  agents
folder, and the  Claude one is just
a shortcut to it, so that Claude code
can also recognize it and use it without
having duplicates in the same project.
Now, inside that folder, the skill file
is the one holding all the guidance for
the agent on how to use this. And once
that's done, the skill is installed and
you're ready to start using it. But
before you do, there's one thing you
need to know. If you run this skill
exactly as it is, it takes a really long
time to get anything meaningful built.
We found that out testing it on an app.
That session ran for around 3 to 4 hours
straight, and when we checked the
progress, there was just a login page
and nothing else. Since we went through
the skill, we found that the problem was
in its instructions. Both Claude code
and Codex can run several agents at the
same time, and each sub-agent can work
in parallel on a different task. But
this skill hands out one task, waits for
it to complete, and only then hands out
the next one. So, even though it was
running agents, it was not using these
agents' capabilities to full extent, and
that's where all those hours went. So,
we opened the project back up and
changed the skill itself. And you can
pause here and copy the prompt we used
if you want to change it yourself. What
it does is get the skill to actually use
the fact that these tools can run
several agents at once. Then to run it,
you type the skill name, then the depth
of the tree, and then you write out
everything you want built. Since we were
building this demo app from scratch, we
went with five. But you pick that number
based on the size of your own task. If
you want to work on a feature rather
than a whole app in one go? Two or three
would be enough for you. And you don't
have to worry about selecting the wrong
option because if you picked higher than
needed, it will automatically lower the
depth for you. And the first thing it
does before it builds anything is
writing the plan.md file and then the
gates.md file. In the plan.md, it also
mentions which task is to work with
which file so that if two agents are
working at the same time, they don't
overwrite each other's work. Then it
lays the foundation and starts handing
the work out to the agents all running
at the same time. And with those fixes
in, 10 agents were working at once, each
on different parts of it. That run went
for nearly 2 hours. At the end, we got
the first version of our demo app
running with all the features working
exactly as we wanted. And if you're
building at this kind of scale, you can
also pair this with a model router
skill. That's basically one that sends
each task to the right model for it. So,
the simple mechanical work goes to a
cheaper model and the hard parts go to
the strong one so that it doesn't hit
your limits soon. Now, this skill we
used here was built through multiple
rounds of testing and refining. If you
want this skill, you can get that in AI
Labs Pro, which is our community. So, if
you found value in what we do and want
to support the channel, this is the
right way to do it. The link's in
description. That brings us to the end
of this video. If you'd like to support
the channel and help us keep making
videos like this, you can do so by using
the Super Thanks button below. As
always, thank you for watching and I'll
see you in the next one.